hey what's going on everybody
i am dave rubin this is the reuben
report direct message for today
may 6 2021 and of course 10 seconds
before i start doing this live stream i
open up my phone
nothing good could possibly be happening
on the phone and i just saw this video
that's going viral right now
just this woman not wearing a mask at a
store and some guy
you know the pretend good guy the virtue
signaling good guy you
killed my grandparents so the woman's
like you know she's a young healthy
woman she's like you know i'm pregnant
you're wearing a mask everyone here is
vaccinated we can just go about living
our lives can we you killed grandma
and grandpa these people it's really a
mental disorder i tweeted out this
morning
at this point if you're wearing a mask
outdoors
now that happened to be indoors in a
store and i don't know what the policy
of the store was
although i think we're gonna have to
start ignoring that too because
otherwise we'll never move forward here
but if you're wearing a mask outdoors
you've got a mental condition and we got
to deal with it i don't know
i don't know if it's a it's a medication
or a therapy
or you got to go down to costa rica do
some ayahuasca but we got to figure this
stuff out because we can't live like
this much longer
uh anyway i'm in a great mood today
there's a lot going on in the world
uh we are doing a q a we got a gajillion
questions roughly a gajillion we added
them up it was close to a gajillion
at reubenreport.locals.com but before we
do that i always like to do these q and
a's with leading
with one story so you guys know my
feelings about
ron desantis he's he's the last hope for
america the guy
is just doing everything right he is the
right
blend of a true leader but someone who's
also respecting individual liberty he
doesn't want the government
to do everything but knows when to use
the light touch of government
and just yesterday he announced that
florida
will be giving one thousand dollar
bonuses to law enforcement officials
and first responders let's take a look
i asked the legislature in this
legislative session we need to do
bonuses
for law enforcement someone to fund
some want to fund the police we're
funding the police
and then some all right so let me give
you a little context to that from
florida.gov
208 million dollars has been allocated
from the department of economic
opportunity
for over a hundred seventy four thousand
first responders across the state
including about forty nine thousand law
enforcement officers
forty thousand emts thirty five thousand
firefighters
and thirty three 000 paramedics in
florida that means they're all getting a
thousand bucks
i don't live in florida but i just want
to say to all of you that are getting it
you deserve it
i wish that we were doing it to our
first responders
and our law enforcement here in
california but we got bigger problems
here
at the moment uh but ron desantis is is
what a true leader is he's playing
this game perfectly and i think it may
come up in one of the questions in the q
a i just quickly glanced through them
but this idea that some states are
really doing it right and some states
are really doing it wrong
i know that feels unnerving right
because it feels like the country's
splitting but in many ways
that is the beauty of the united states
of america that is federalism that
allows us
to live in places that are more in line
with our beliefs and our lifestyle and
the type of people we want to
be around and for all of you that are
saying but dave you're in california
i'm not the perfect man and we're
thinking about things uh okay so let's
get to
uh some q a here uh but before i do that
i want to talk to you guys about 1-800
flowers
if you didn't know mother's day is just
a couple days away guys
a mother is someone who loves you with
all her heart so whether it's your mom
your stepmom or a strong maternal figure
this mother's day celebrate all the
amazing women in your life with a
gorgeous bouquet
from 1 800 flowers dot com right now 1
800 flowers is offering 24
multi-colored roses plus a free vaz for
34.99 this gorgeous bouquet of two dozen
roses and an assortment of bright colors
is guaranteed to show all of the moms in
your life just how much they are loved
i cannot wait to send a 1 800 flowers
bouquet to my mom actually i did send
one my mom
got one yesterday my sister-in-law got
one and my sister and i told them they
could enjoy it for a few days even
before mother's day
all the roses from 1 800 flowers are
packed at their peak cared for every
step of the way and shipped fresh
to ensure lasting beauty picking an
early delivery date ensures that your
bouquet will
arrive in time to make mother's day
special 24
multi-colored roses plus a free vase for
34.99 is an amazing offer but prices
will be going up
so order today you're running out of
time don't put this offer off
order today from the official florist of
mother's day 1800 flowers.com
to order 24 multi-colored roses plus a
free boz for 34.99 go to 1-800 flowers
dot com
click the radio icon and enter the code
ruben that's 1-800 flowers.com
code reuben and now back to me okay so
we are doing
a ask me anything q a these were all
questions submitted at
reubenreport.locals.com by the way
i should note guys that yesterday uh was
basically
our biggest one-day growth ever
at our locals community i i made this
offer that if you signed up annually
yesterday
not only do you always get two months
free if you do the annual subscription
but i'm signing all sorts of cards and
i'm gonna personalize some things and
write your name in it and we had a huge
explosion over there so there's just
just a great amount of stuff going on on
the community so we got a ton of
questions i had michael review
everything and i said mix it up today
so let's see what happens here we go
neil says keeping it simple dave
how are you um i'm good
i'm pretty good i really am pretty good
you know uh let's put aside the
revolution
for the moment and just like all the
worries that we all have like
everyone's worried about something right
like the thing
the big broad thing about what's
happening in the state of the world in
the state of the country doesn't feel
that great it feels like things are kind
of out of control
it feels like we don't have adults in
the room it feels like you know as i
always talk about the the
elite class has just failed us all
together all of that stuff but let's put
that aside for a moment
my day is pretty good like i wake up
with purpose i love doing this show you
know i used to only really do the
interviews and then we shifted
to this direct message thing i love
doing this i love connecting with you
guys you know we've done a couple live
meetups over the last
couple months i love seeing people and
hugging people i always tell you people
people always want to touch me they
can't believe i'm a real person they
want to touch me and hug me
usually i let them not not in every case
sometimes it could be weird
um but i just i feel that i'm doing good
work
i love the people that i'm working with
david and i are good we eat good food
we live in the right house like we're
happy you know what i always say david
is
the stuff that goes on in our four walls
here
is great like our day-to-day is great
and i realized also i don't leave the
house that often at this point because i
work
from here like we've got the stuff that
we want i don't really want more
physical stuff like we've got stuff
like wednesday i haven't bought a shoe
or i guess i did get new sneakers the
other day but i haven't bought like a
shirt or just pant like you guys just
don't need more stuff
so i feel very good about like where i'm
at in life
and i just hope that what we're doing
here can make a difference i think it is
making a difference you guys often tell
me it's making a difference
so i would say like i'm pretty good we
have friends coming over for dinner
tonight as you guys know we eat good
food we drink good wine
and you know i'm just i'm just trying to
fight the good fight and i would
actually
uh you know throw you back to that
jordan peterson video that we put up a
couple days ago about what
truth is you know like jordan said that
he started to say
i'm going to say the truth and let's see
what happens and it doesn't always mean
that everything will be great but it
will be the best possible alternative
by putting truth out there and i'm
really trying to do that
and i think the more that we all do that
that's the only way we're going to
correct this thing
and he also said that that's really the
ultimate expression of faith if you just
say i'm going to say the truth
for truth's sake because it's got to be
better than the alternative it's got to
be better than the lie that might get
you some temporary
satisfaction or something like that like
that actually is faith that's a leap of
faith i will say the truth
just because that's the right thing to
do like that's the leap of faith right
there
and i'm really trying to do that and i
think it's given me a broader
sense of what the world is and i hope
that answers your question i'm doing
pretty well and i hope you are as well
velda says uh hear from caitlyn jenner
yet any insights
from the hannity interview so we have
not heard back from caitlyn jenner yet
we have reached out across all possible
channels and i've
done a little push on twitter i did
watch the hannity interview and let me
say this
if you would have said to me 20 years
ago that bruce jenner
will be running as a woman to be the
governor of california and you dave
will probably be supporting her i would
have said you were bananas that being
said
here we are and it's a strange time in
2021 and so far it seems to me that she
is the best
candidate out there there are a couple
others and i'm interested in
talking to anyone that that actually is
legit my main concern with caitlyn is i
want to know
that this thing is legit and this is not
just for a reality show
and for press and buzz and you know
making people money and that kind of
thing
so i thought her answers on hannity last
night were excellent she talked about
lowering taxes and doing better on
immigration and homelessness and
you know that we always talk about these
nonsensical trans issues which are just
so
not important and in a way it shows you
how the left does
dominate the culture war because they
get us to talk about these things
all the time something that affects so
few people and it's not that you don't
care about those people in the
individual cases it's just that it's
become the dominant narrative
but even that that she doesn't want
biological boys in girls sports like
she said all of the right stuff so
i hope i can interview her and i would
also say this if if caitlyn
if you're watching or if any of your
people are watching and you're on the
fence about doing a longer form
unedited interview you know one of the
things that finally moved me on donald
trump when i was really kind i couldn't
figure it out and i was like ah
something still
ain't right here like i kept saying i
said this to candace owens many times
privately i would say you know i really
just need to meet the guy because she'd
be saying you know
he really is a great guy and he's not a
racist and he's not a homophobe and blah
blah
say well i need to meet him and then i
think most of you know the story of when
david and i went to mar-a-lago
and we met trump and i got to spend some
time with him and i saw that him and
melania actually loved each other it was
so obvious
and that he didn't care about anyone's
sexuality and he certainly didn't care
about race
and i got to see it like right there in
front of me and that that gave me some
insight
i sort of feel like i want that same
experience with with caitlyn
so i hope i get to interview her and
anyone
on planet earth is better than gavin
newsom
who is an evil cartoon character from a
disney movie
uh mana says why do conservatives seem
to never speak from the same script
the way democrats do our messaging is
lame at best well
there's a really interesting point to
this conservatives libertarians you know
whatever this new thing on the right is
believe in individual rights within
individual rights
what you meaning the government's going
to treat us the same but you can
live differently right like there's the
more libertarian side of that that maybe
is okay with but
there's the more conservative side of it
that maybe is more you know
sort of traditionally religious or
something like that but everyone
has the basic ideas that oh we just want
the government to treat us equally
and then there can be a lot of fighting
within that or
not it's not even i don't even see it
really as fighting i actually see it as
a very healthy expression of like
which way do we want the country to go
and how do we respect people with
different
thoughts and and who have different
lifestyles and all that stuff
that's why i see something so rich
happening on the right the democrats are
better about the script
because they believe at least in a
modern sense
and i would love to hear pushback on
this from somebody i mean give me a give
me a blue check
legit democrat lefty who doesn't do
personal attacks
and who will have an honest conversation
about this there is nothing
left on the left in terms of sort of the
bedrock belief system like it used to be
sort of like i'm liberal like i want
some level of change
meaning i want to change things to be
more equal that made sense once they put
in the equity thing and then they
combined it with government doing
everything right government will solve
all of your problems if we just
tax this guy enough if we just take from
that guy
if we just have enough power and we can
get everybody into government schools
and we can get everybody into
bernie's college brainwash centers if we
can if you just give us enough power if
you just become a tiny cog
in a much bigger system then everything
will be better
and you will be happy or as palpatine
said and then we shall
have peace that is the problem that
their
goal is power it's not about
freeing people it's about actually
enslaving people if you really think
about it just give us the power
to decide absolutely everything that
will happen in society
and then you will somehow be happier
that message although it's a horrific
message
when you really understand it it's very
easy to just fall in line and then you
know the other thing about your question
is about the same script the other thing
is they're so
culty in nature that what position are
you allowed to take
that say the woke left or the
progressives or really anyone in the
democratic party at this point doesn't
take what what diversity is there of
thought
within the democratic party now you can
say to me dave what's what's the
diversity in the republican party well
actually
there's plenty of diversity in the
republican party somebody like rudy
giuliani who at one time
they thought was going to be president
it seems like a while ago but it's only
10 or 12 years ago when he was running
and then he had to step down because he
had cancer but he's a pro-choice
republican
right he was for gay marriage before
that there are still some republicans
that aren't for gay marriage there are
some that are
for the marijuana discussion certain
stuff on states rights
as i said the the abortion thing like
there's but people aren't crushing and
destroying each other over it
and purging people the left is doing
that so i think they stay on the same
script because they're actually in a
self-hostage situation
and i'd much rather hang out with people
who can
agree to disagree and it's going to be a
little messier and it's also going to
make
it's going to make it much harder to win
that's the key
thing if you have a bunch of people that
don't want to use
all of the lever of levers of power to
make
everyone bow to their beliefs well then
the people who want to do all that stuff
they can grab the power more easily and
that's
that's sort of the tough one right now
really the tough one for libertarians
more than anything else
the libertarians who are just like hey i
just want to live my life i want to
smoke my weed and bang my hookers and
grow my
you know mushrooms and it's like great
i'm all for all you do whatever you want
to do on your property that's just fine
except if they keep
moving on you and i think florida is
going to deal with a version of this
it's like florida is going to do
all the right stuff but if the democrats
just keep giving more and more power to
the federal government it's like is the
federal government going to start
encroaching on states rights i have no
doubt
that they will carlton says after
yesterday with facebook once again
banning president trump
what is your projection of the future
for conservatives and moderate voices
being heard
do you have any hope well i don't have
hope related to big tech i really don't
like
every one of us and anyone who has a
flicker of independent thought
anyone that has any of that that has any
sort of divergent view
or thinks for themselves or just is
occasionally
a contrarian uh you're in a lot of
trouble like big tech
is not going to turn around the idea
that 19
people basically all leftist activists
like show me the conservative on the
facebook oversight committee that
decided the fate of trump it's like
who's more powerful those 19 people
or the former president of the united
states you know who's left now
to basically blogging on his own site um
they have
way too much power the idea that they
were going to actually debate like the
real issues related
to free speech and say the first
amendment and facebook being a private
company but has a lot of governmental
power and tons of money
and the backdoor access that we know
that these companies have and everything
else
if you are just sitting on youtube and
on facebook
and on twitter whether you're someone
that creates content or you just consume
content
if if you think that you know that this
is just going to keep going forever
it ain't they will keep narrowing that
alley they will keep saying oh no no
that can't be said that can't be said
that can't be said that can't be said
they will do it on the creator side
through demonetization so
if you talk about certain things and
then you get demonetized that's not
direct
censorship right but i run a business
here so we know if i talk about certain
things if i say
certain words if i was to say something
about the election
my god they could not only demonetize me
which then i have to run a business so
it's like oh should i talk about the
things that are
never going to make me any money because
i do have to pay my guys right like and
i have to pay myself like that's just
reality so that's a soft type of
censorship but they could also delete
any of our channels like
face this is the thing that i keep
trying to explain to people youtube
could just tomorrow if they've had
enough if the democrats and the powers
that be have had enough
they could tomorrow just announce okay
guys next week we're closing up shop on
youtube
we're only going to have networks on
here or or otherwise verified channels
so everyone that is just creating
anything or consuming anything just on
these things you're making a huge
mistake
by the way that's exactly why i started
locals.com i don't need to
make a big commercial yesterday because
i obviously talked about about it
yesterday but if i was booted off
everything
today well i have we have thousands and
thousands and thousands of people that
are in our locals community
i have an app i have direct access for a
push notification
live streaming is coming like all our
videos are there we own all of it and
that's
why we built the company because it was
obvious that this was all accompanying
and coming and that's why we want to
give this technology to other people so
do i have hope well i would say as i say
to most things i'm a world weary
optimist i believe that david can beat
goliath that story
has some meaning the little guy can
always win
um but it ain't easy right it ain't easy
although for david i guess it was pretty
easy just a slingshot and he took the
guy out but uh
you know okay uh landon says you believe
trump wasn't going to run in 2024 what
do you make of his comments
on candace's show last tuesday so if you
didn't see it
trump called into candace's daily wire
show did a phoner which i always think
is so funny like he's like the last guy
that does
phone interviews um and candace
basically asked him you know are you
going to run in 2024.
and in a very trump style thing he said
well a lot of people are
talking about it a lot of people are
very interested and i've had i i would
like to say that i have some good news
you know but i can't do it too early
because there's some fundraising stuff
and it can make it complex but i think
when i do make the decision a lot of
people are gonna be very happy look
trump is a showman right
like there's no doubt trump's a showman
he knows how to keep everybody sort of
focused on him
and he does seem to be getting back into
the spotlight my feeling
my gut feeling and i obviously i could
be wrong about this obviously i could be
wrong
is that he won't run but he will be
the the energy he will be the the
movement is still him so when you see
this sort of
divide in the republicans now it's like
the mitt romney liz
cheney wing that's very small wing it's
just the two of them
and then pretty much everybody else but
the media really loves them right the
media really loves liz cheney right now
and they really love mitt romney because
they're pet republicans they can have
they can go on msnbc and they'll say
nice things about them
because they know that they're
ineffectual they make no difference they
stand for no conservative principle
they would fold like a wet paper bag and
the rest of it um
what would be better than trump running
to me is that he acts as
the energy keeps the rallies going gets
everybody excited again you know that we
can be proud of america again that the
government
is not here to run your life um and all
of that
stuff that was the good part of trump
but the polarization around him it's
like we could get a better candidate so
i like the idea of desantis running
let desantis run the guy first of all
he's also much younger i think he's 44
years old right like we could use a gen
x person i i happen to be 44 as well can
we confirm
desantis age like we could use we we
haven't handed this stuff over we've let
the baby boomers hold on for too long
which
at some level is because science is good
and you can be in your late 70s early
80s and still somewhat functional
although i think the ship has sailed on
that joe biden fella
but if trump can act as basically like
the digital bodyguard take the heat
get the media focused over there and
desantis could come in and be like oh
here are the policies and we don't want
to defund the police
and you know in my state of florida we
don't have an income tax
and that's pretty good that's why people
want to come here and we let people live
freely and by the way
a slight sidebar but i met with my
business managers on friday and we
looked at the numbers and i was like so
if i moved to florida can you just show
me the numbers like what are we looking
at
and i'm a [ __ ] idiot what am i doing
here i mean i get it the weather is nice
but florida's nice it's the humidity
the humidity because it makes the hair
you know lower
where in florida here in california no
humidity
it works for me anyway desantis is 42
years old so i i still think that trump
as sort of the outsider
playing in the political sphere is
probably better because for the people
that still have that
that trump derangement syndrome thing
it's like well hold on now you give me
desantis
and say candace owens you give me
desantis
and say tim scott you give me desantis
and say nikki haley
you give me desantis and say dan
crenshaw i mean we can figure out what
all those pieces are
while trump is acting as the thing
that's going to be the defender now the
question is can he do it
can he do it and look i may be wrong
maybe he will run
and there could be value in that as well
uh
yates says dave for those of us who work
full-time and have a family how can we
best contribute our limited free time
towards combating the wokeness disease
in your opinion where can we make
positive impact
most effectively i suspect you're doing
it already because you have a job and a
family
and if you're just a decent person and
in whatever interactions you have either
at your kid's school
local community when you go to your
store
gardener comes over whatever it might be
if you just
say what you believe you know just say
what you believe you know yesterday
actually
we had a guy here was was fixing a light
in the pool
and he was wearing a mask and it was
like 95 degrees out yesterday it was
hot as hell and when i got out of that
he came when i was in studio doing the
show when i got out there i looked
and i see this guy and he's dripping
with sweat he's got the mask on it was a
young
young guy and i said hey i walked out
there i was like hey just fyi
i don't know what your company policy is
but you don't have to wear the mask
you're out here alone and
you know we're completely fine with that
and he took it off and he was dripping
with sweat but he had like the biggest
smile on his face like oh thanks man
like this thing's horrible and it's like
i think i did like a little
it's not me that did it really but it
was just like a little moment of like
yeah can we just be humans with each
other you're also outdoors it's hot as
hell
like i think if you can ju whatever it
is in that those little
interactions that you can do because
then
what happened after that was we didn't
talk politics but it was just like
we were it was just like there was this
unsaid thing like oh you're a human and
i'm a human and we can still be human
with each other
and i think that's what you can do
that's best and and just do good for
your family do good for your family
which i have no doubt that you're doing
shirinyu says have you decided whether
or not to get the vaccine
oh sharin roo you're trying to get me
banned from the youtube and my family
um i don't want to get the vaccine i see
no need
as a relatively young relatively healthy
person to get it
at the moment i live in a state with
endlessly good weather especially here
in socal if you want to get the vaccine
i think you should get the vaccine if
you want to wear a mask i think you
should
get the mask you know i've been out and
about in this last year i've gone to
trump rallies
without masks i was in florida without
mass i don't wear masks out here
if i went if i go even even right now if
i go into a store i do
follow the policies of the store i'm not
thrilled to do it it usually seems
pretty ridiculous to me just this
weekend i was at home depot
like in the garden section it's outdoors
but it's outdoors but
it's indoors because there's like a
metal facade and i took off my mask and
they asked me to put it back on there's
like a series of crazy things going on
here
but if you are
someone that want to take the vaccine
you should and if you don't
i don't think you should have to i know
that this got joe rogan in a whole bunch
of hot water last week and then he kind
of backtracked it
but it is my personal belief and i and i
think if i'm not mistaken
that in america you're still allowed to
have a personal belief
my personal belief is that if you are in
a risk group or even if you're not
if you're perfectly young and healthy
and you're 32 in the
and the peak of fitness you still can
take it if you want to take it but we
shouldn't be
forcing people to take it and we have to
just move on it's time to move on
even even if there was a second outbreak
and covid 6 and now they're going to
tell us about the chilean variant and
everything else we got to move on
because this is not about covet anymore
you saw the picture i'm sure that was
viral in the last couple days of a
little
kindergarten or or preschool it looked
like with the kids sitting in hula hoops
with masks and the teacher has a mask
and it's like
do you see what you're doing to children
this has nothing to do with covet
anymore first off that woman obviously
is vaccinated you have two
three-year-olds in masks which makes no
sense
what do you think is going to happen to
these kids when they're 12 15 18
22 what you will have trained them to
accept we will forget
what the old world is and i'm a stickler
man i ain't forgetting just yet
marissa says do you think the majority
of states will look to florida as the
measure of sanity and decency as the
data continues to support the reopening
well look the people that tell you to
believe in the science usually don't
believe in the science right i mean if
they believe in the science and then you
say well are there biological
differences
between males and females and they'll
tell you you're a racist so it's like
i don't think they really care about
data and that's what i've been trying to
say to you guys that so much of this has
to do with control and fear
more than the virus itself that is just
my personal belief which again i think
you're still allowed to have
in the united states at least for the
next few months so
i don't think that there's anything
really that
can sort of shift the people of the
leadership say of california as it
stands now or the leadership of new york
or new jersey
or michigan that they would suddenly be
like you know um
actually things are better in texas
things are better
they can't the left if i've learned one
thing over the last you know six years
of my political evolution
the left always doubles down there is
never a maya culpa there is never a
moment of
boy the data doesn't look right to us or
maybe these people aren't all racist
maybe these people aren't all homophobes
even when they get wins
they actually double down to their worst
sort of
uh base ideas so for example like the
gay marriage thing it's like gay
marriage is here
nobody's fighting against it anymore and
it's like they still run around calling
all the republicans
homophobes so so good news and bad news
always causes them to sort of become
their worst selves and it would be too
much of an admission
like do you think it would be possible
for gretchen whitmer in michigan
or gavin newsom in california who still
has the state locked down until june
15th which is still over a month from
now
do you think it would be possible to be
like oh you know actually guys
we looked at the numbers here and uh
everything i've done for the last year
and a half makes no sense we've
destroyed the economy we've crushed
dreams
we've gotten people hooked on drugs
homelessness has exploded everything
else
florida's done it right so sorry about
that
what are you gonna do like i don't think
avenue some coming coming
around on that kind of stuff melo says
where does your inspiration come from
is your business temperament calm rushed
or annoyed
well is my business temperament i guess
i could ask these guys um
you know i run pretty cool i think all
of us are sort of wired
a certain way right some people are
really wired hot
some people are wired cool my my general
demeanor is pretty cool
it takes a lot to piss me off it takes a
lot for me to get kind of crazy you guys
see it every now and again here when i
drop an f-bomb or and which sometimes
i'm usually trying not to do but i just
can't take it anymore like i can't take
it anymore i don't have like an ethical
issue really dropping the curses but
actually we do know that if i say curses
it demonetizes us hurts us in the
algorithm and the rest
of it anyway sidebar i'm i'm pretty
calm and cool i think it's why i'm a
halfway decent interviewer and i can sit
across from somebody and they can say
something you know that i don't like or
that i don't agree with and it doesn't
seem to me
to be an affront to my humanity you know
one of the
clips that that people give me the most
crap for is when ben shapiro was
describing his own personal religious
belief on gay marriage and that we could
sit there and respect
each other like i can do that i can do
that and i don't think it's my job to
bludgeon
religious people into believing
something that i believe
as long as i'm equal under the law which
i am um
so i i at no point in that did i want to
punch the guy
um but your real question is where does
my inspiration come from
um you know now i would say it comes
from
the belief that i can affect things a
little bit right like we i guess we
would all want to affect things
in the world in some degree and by the
way you don't have to have a youtube
channel or
be on tv to affect things like from the
question earlier like about
parenting and what can i do it's like
you're affecting things if you're
raising your kids right
you're affecting things if you're
standing for up for what you believe in
so i think my inspiration now is like i
don't know how this all happened
but like i'm in this fight and sometimes
i you know people say to me a lot
like dave you're brave or you say what
you think or and it's so scary or you're
not
you aren't you afraid of getting
canceled and everything it's like well i
guess i went through a lot of it like i
went through all the hit pieces and new
york times and i've seen all the
[ __ ] and i've been through it so
like
it didn't kill me so you get out on the
other side and you're like well here i
am and it's like
so i guess like could could the another
hit piece come that could
turn people on me could another mob come
you know like all the things could all
the things happen
um i guess they could i guess they could
but like what kind of person
do i want to be what kind of person do
you want to be do you want to be someone
that doesn't do what they think they
should do because
because it's easier or because because
fear is your dominant
value or do you want to be someone that
says hey here i am better or worse
let's do this thing and that that's the
one that works for me
all right two more people here we go uh
rhiannon says what is your favorite
alcoholic beverage and what home-cooked
food would you pair it with good
question
um so you guys know i'm a big red wine
guy uh and you can go to
freethinkerwine.com by the way and get
some
delicious malbecs um but uh i've really
been into tequila lately i've been on a
tequila kick for about
about two months we have uh some friends
here who are big tequila drinkers and
they got me into tequila
and we're doing some sipping tequilas
now and i'm making some mixed drinks and
something
there's a bottle uh it ain't cheap i
will warn you it ain't cheap but you
only need to it's a sipping tequila so
you can drink very small amount of it
i think it's called claws clausa zuul
someone correct me it's a big beautiful
hand-painted bottle it's like 120 bucks
a bottle or something
claus azul am i right yeah klaus azul
and it's a sipping tequila i mean if you
have
two little ones on ice you're good to go
man and there's something different
about the sort of buzz that you're going
to get
from red wine red wine strikes me as
more of a depressing as i said i run
cool so i like
i can have wine and just i'm like i'm
good you know
where tequila it's a little more like
you're up you're up you're ready to go
and uh and actually we are having dinner
tonight with some friends
and uh we will be having some tequila
i'm told it's 129 a bottle
so it ain't cheap but as i said you only
need just a tiny bit
and last question for today i like this
mix guys uh
zionist says you said you're moving
locals to miami
you're staying in socal for now how will
that work so we are moving locals to
miami there's a million reasons to do it
as you guys know the entire tech world
is moving to miami right now oh and by
the way
i actually haven't said this publicly
yet but why not i'm going to miami
in a couple weeks i think middle of june
i will be interviewing
uh the mayor of miami francis suarez who
has been i'm going to do it at on
location
we're either doing it at city hall or we
might do it uh
at one of the local investors homes
because we thought that would be kind of
cool to just show that like there's such
there's such like energy and it's just
so cool what's going on there um but he
is welcoming people and
and not only are they making it friendly
for these businesses and saying hey
flee that freaking dystopian nightmare
of san francisco come here build your
businesses
but then as you know there's no state
income tax in florida as i said before
like i would have a lot more money if if
i moved
there we're moving locals there so my my
co-founder
is moving there we're moving most of the
team there by the way we have um
developers all over the world so we have
an incredible team i'm so proud of what
we built
it's actually pretty slim trim operation
we are hiring people right now which is
great
um for me look i have a business here i
have people that work for me here we're
constantly having discussions about all
of these things
i want to stay and fight for now which
by the way is one of the things that
caitlyn jenner
said last night hannity said well you
know what's going on here why are you
doing this
and she basically was like you know i
have so many friends and co-workers and
colleagues
that are leaving right and no one's
moving to california everyone's fleeing
right um
but i believe in that stay and fight
thing and you guys probably know the
story of knowles and i
michael knowles from daily wire like
eight months ago
him and his wife came over we're having
dinner at our house we're drinking
uh we were doing whiskey that night and
we're drunk and we're like going on and
i'm like we're going to stay and fight
man we're going to get rid of newsome
we're going to save the state
and then literally the next morning
daily wire announced that they were
moving to nashville and then
noles went to nashville which i was in
nashville last week
and oh and actually speaking of drinking
and michael knowles when i was in
nashville last week with knowles
we did this really fun game where
basically it was we had to
we had questions asked to us that were
pre-written questions that neither one
of us knew about our political beliefs
and we had to guess what the other
person's response was and then drink
if we got it wrong and then we pretty
much drank if we got it right too
so that'll be coming out on saturday on
the daily wire and noel's new book is
coming out
the guy's just an absolute all-star but
anyway
we have some other considerations
because i have businesses here we have
some personal stuff
that has tied us here a little bit but
we're really trying to figure it out
trust me we're trying to figure out but
i want to stay in a fight
like and again i say this all the time
but but really think about it
really think about if someone like me
who who their
most of their life was a lefty who by
any real estimation is a political
moderate
um putting aside my personal life and
all that kind of stuff if someone like
me truly can't live
in california anymore then what does
that say about california and then what
is and
and if that is really where we're at
then what does that say
about the state of the union and perhaps
that is why the founders did what they
did
they wanted that federal government to
be so weak and thin
so that you would be able to and it
would be incumbent actually on you
to move to a place that was more in line
with your views and you know i do
believe that i believe that's the right
thing to do
but that doesn't mean everyone has to
pick up and run like some people fight
but as i say to everybody no matter when
this conversation comes up
i don't want to be the last guy in dodge
so so we shall see
that is as honest an answer as i can
possibly tell you uh guys i enjoyed the
q a thank you for all the questions and
again welcome to all the new members at
reubenreport.locals.com
uh part three of my interview with nikki
haley
former uh governor of south carolina and
former u.s ambassador to the u.n
is up on youtube right now the full
episode is already up of course ad free
at ruben report.locals.com oh and uh
tomorrow
is today thursday today's thursday yeah
tomorrow uh god i got so much going on
at once it's like what day is it man
um tomorrow we're doing a panel on
canada because if you haven't been
tracking what's going on
if you think we've got some
authoritarian weirdo stuff going on in
california and new york and michigan and
everything else
like canada really seems incredibly
bizarre so we have three
canadians on the show michaela peterson
who you guys all know viva fry
the lawyer who's been on the show once
before and as uh ezra levant
from the rebel will all be joining me to
dissect what's going on in canada we may
throw in some videos because there's
just some really awful draconian
lockdown stuff
and we will unpack that and more anyway
i enjoyed the show
go out there have a nice day find some
purpose find some meaning see what
happens
and uh you know we'll be back tomorrow
no big deal huh
okay
you